All right, Andy Cohen,
thank you for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm great. How are you doing, Michael?
I am just fine.
How have you been dealing
with this whole covid situation,
working from home?
You know, it's been great.
My company that I'm working for now,
Bill.com, we sell a cloud application
for paying your bills
when you're not in your office.
So, we're living by that.
We're 600 people all working remotely
and haven't missed a beat.
So, we're doing perfectly well,
and I'm getting more time with my family,
which is nice.
So, I'm doing great.
I love it.
Okay. So, just to start off.
SVP of sales at Bill.com,
a 600 person company working remotely.
Give me your two cents
on what were some of the most
meaningful leadership changes
that occurred as you transition
from in-office to all working from home,
as you're an executive
within a 600 person company,
what were some of your
personal challenges or changes
that you had to adapt to?
So, I run a 100 person sales team
with Bill.com,
where we really thrive off
each others energy,
we're mostly together in Palo Alto
in a bullpen, high five
and ringing the gong.
Having a great time when we sell at Bill's.
Wait, there's an actual gong?
Oh, of course there's a gong.
And so, what I was worried
when we got the one week notice
to go remote
is how do you keep that energy.
Because so much of sales is the energy.
And I'm just so proud and grateful
to the team that we've been able
to replicate a lot of that online.
Not all of it, but a lot of that.
So, with one week notice,
everybody goes home.
And it's people in their 20s and 30s
that don't at all have the best
work environment.
They were sometimes still living
with their parents,
or they're in crowded apartments.
And so, everybody's scrambled.
Fortunately, we're all busy
because Bill.com is an application
that small businesses
use to pay bills remotely.
And so, it's tailor made
for being a remote business.
So, our business has been doing well.
That helps.
But also we've every day
we do Zoom stand ups.
We've done, we do Zoom happy hours.
We even did a quota club dinner
where I sent everybody steak
and a bottle of wine
and we all have dinner together.
And so, we're trying to do
as much as we can.
And I think long term,
we all want to be back together again.
But for short term, we're making it work.
I think, that's incredible.
I think it's always fascinating to hear
how different companies
transition to this time,
especially coming in
from a leadership position where a lot of,
and I'm sure that these 100 people
are looking up at you and saying,
"Okay. Well, Andy, what do we do now?"
"How is our culture going to look like?"
Every person comes in with their own
set of deliberations and their worries.
But, Andy, I want to go back a little bit.
And you did Stanford, Kellogg,
transition to Deloitte,
to different startups, and Caring.com.
When I saw Caring.com
and your involvement with it,
I got so inspired.
I'm very passionate about the issue
of using technology to help those
that are aging.
I'm especially looking at my own family,
and it's getting more and more difficult
to have coherent communication
and to take care of them.
Especially as we're in a remote setting
where it's not ideal to just go and visit
and be with them all the time.
Talk to me a little bit about
the founding and management of Caring.com
and where that went.
Yeah. And just backing up
a little bit, Michael,
my view on a business career is,
a lot of people, I think,
start their career
and they want to have a plan.
I want to do this for five years,
this for five years.
I'm going to get these skills
and it's going to be able to do this.
And I look at the business career
as 30% having the skills
and 70% reacting to opportunities.
I'm 56.
I've had a 35-year business career.
And it's like a whitewater rafting.
If you're down a river and there's rocks
and you're navigating,
you can know how to paddle the boat,
you can have a good boat,
but you don't know
what's around the corner.
And so, I think, if I was giving advice
to young people, I'd be like,
"Get all the skills and be prepared."
But you're riding down a wild river.
You don't know what's around the corner.
But when you see the smooth water,
you can go for it.
When you see the waterfall,
you can avoid it.
You just have to be prepared.
But it's only 30% under your control.
70% is going to be the river,
and how you react to it.
That's my view on business.
So, Caring.com
was one of those situations.
I was in the position
of losing both my parents at a young age.
My dad had a heart attack and died at 67.
And then my mom got lung cancer
shortly thereafter.
She was living in Chicago.
I was living in Silicon Valley.
I was in a demanding job
and I was flying back and forth
trying to help her on the weekends.
And it was an awful time
because I love my mom very much
and we were very close.
It was horrible watching her struggle.
And then it was also horrible,
I was a MBA, a smart business guy,
trying to help her navigate
the health care system,
trying to help her try to hire a nurse,
navigate Medicare, deal with end of life.
And I just felt so unprepared.
And after she passed away, it was awful.
I ended up taking time off
and talking to other people and said,
"Well, how did you how did you deal
with all this end of life stuff?"
When you're planning your wedding,
you can talk to your parents,
you can find all these websites.
When you're having a baby,
you can read books.
But when you're losing a parent,
it's very difficult.
How do you know what to do?
And everybody told me
that had lost a parent,
they had no idea what to do.
So, I said,
"Hey, there's websites
for wedding planning."
"There's websites for having a baby."
"There should be a website
for caring for aging parent."
And it's tough stuff.
But if you can help someone,
you're doing God's work.
You're helping them through probably
the most difficult period in their life,
losing a parent.
So, I started Caring.com with that mission.
And it wasn't that
I had this whole business plan
that I said,
"Okay. There's an aging population."
"There's going to be a lot of caregivers."
"This is going to be a big business."
It was like,
"Hey, I went through
this horrible experience
and I knew that I could help
people through this website."
And so, starting Caring.com for me
turned out to be a very
good business opportunity.
But it was also very cathartic for me
as a way to get over my grief.
And then, it also was a way to really
get a great team together.
Because what I learned is,
when you have a mission based company,
you can get great great people
that are there
because they really believe
in the mission.
And so, we had an awesome team
at Caring.com that I had no trouble
attracting the best engineers,
keeping the best engineers.
We were venture back,
so we were able to pay market rate.
But also, people really liked
the culture and the mission.
And so, that was such a wonderful period.
I founded it, grew it,
sold it after seven years
because I'd raised venture.
We need an exit.
But through that seven years
had very little turnover
and a great culture and a great fund.
And I'm so proud.
Anything I did before or after,
the proudest part of my career,
was starting a mission-based company
and helping.
We ended up getting
three million visitors a month.
People that were struggling
with caregiving and we were able
to help them make it a little easier.
Wow. That's incredible.
So, give me a little bit of insight
into this market right now.
So, you're talking about the difficulties
of taking care of aging parents
or grandparents,
what are the difficulties?
Is it the lack of information
that's out there?
The lack of resources?
The lack of matching with the right people
to help take care of them?
What are the biggest difficulties there
before you came in to Caring.com
and perhaps today onwards?
Yeah. So, the answer is yes.
It's all difficult.
And unlike other life events,
you have no one to go to for advice.
Because if you're,
let me give you the numbers.
So, there's roughly in the US
two million weddings a year.
And people know that you spend
$50,000 dollars on a wedding,
two million weddings.
There's probably three million babies
born a year in the US,
roughly spend a lot of money on a baby.
There's 45 million people
caring for an aging parent in the US.
And the caregiving period
is a five-year journey on average
where the parent is less independent
and needs the adult child to help them.
They're spending hundreds of thousands
of dollars on housing, on meals,
on equipment, on procedures.
85% of Medicare spending
is on the last year of life.
So, it's just a very expensive, difficult,
emotionally draining.
And all your other life events,
you go to your parents.
You say, "Hey, help me with my wedding."
"Help me with my baby."
You can't say,
"Help me care for you in your death."
because they don't want any help.
They want to be independent.
So, it's just super difficult
all of the above.
And so, from a business standpoint,
there's lots of areas where
I think there's opportunity
on helping making this easier,
both for the caregiver
as well as for the senior.
But a lot of it is for the caregiver.
How do you help them help their parents?
Via technology, via services.
And this is a worldwide issue
because people are living longer,
but they're not living
necessarily independently long.
They're living in
less independent conditions.
And now with the issues with covid,
and senior housing not being safe,
more people are going to be
aging in a home.
And so, they're going to need
more technology and services.
So, I think anyone
is interested in the space.
There's lots of opportunity.
And it's really nice
if you've got your mission
and there's margin.
As a business person,
you can overlap those two
and you don't have to get grants.
You can do something.
You can do God's work
and have it be a business.
And there's so many opportunities there.
That's incredible.
I've been passionate for so long.
Most recently,
I was at a white Y Combinator hackathon
where we developed an app
where we can install a gadget
on my grandmas TV.
And we can then,
through our phone click a button.
It calls her TV,
and she just has to raise her hand
in order to answer the call.
Because lack of dexterity
and lack of tech understanding.
And I became so passionate
about this problem where
just the lack of communication
and the barriers that are rising
between the new generations
and the older generations are so apparent.
That you were looking at the last years,
I'm looking even in the last 20 years
when they're healthy and fine,
but they are not really able
to communicate with the grandkids
and loneliness is one of the
greatest difficulties of that age.
So, and I think it's one of the most
underserviced markets out there.
And I can't wait for people or myself
to go and solve that.
So, I completely agree with you.
Yeah, definitely.
Andy, I want to take us now
to your now most current role.
So, you transitioned.
And what you mentioned was that,
so, your SVP of sales at Bill.com.
And that it actually started
that you were a customer of theirs
for a long time.
You loved their product
and you make that transition, right?
Yeah. So, this is where I talked about,
a business career I think, is a river.
You're just sailing along.
And so I sold my company, Caring.com.
Had a good outcome.
Was trying to think of what to do next.
And I was having lunch with my friend
René Lacerte, who had started
a company called Bill.com.
And I knew Bill.com well
because I was one of their first customers
and I used it at Caring.com.
I also was an investor in the company.
And, so I was having lunch with him
and I said,
"Hey, I'm not sure what I want to do next."
"I have this wonderful experience
with Caring. I had a good outcome."
And he said,
"Hey, why don't you come
help me at Bill.com?"
"We're growing the company."
"We want to go public."
"I need someone to run sales."
"You'd be great at that."
And I said,
I wasn't looking to go
be head of sales, but I liked René.
I like the company's good product,
but then let me do this for a year.
This could be fun.
And that was four years ago.
It's been a ton of fun.
We've take and we've grown
the company 500%.
We've taken it public.
It's been a really good outcome.
But I wasn't looking for that. Right.
That was just something
that came along.
It was a good opportunity.
I jumped on it.
It's been very good for me financially
and it's been fun to be part of IPO,
getting that experience.
But I just wasn't, that was again,
wasn't my plan.
It was like, here's a good opportunity.
It just worked out.
So, give me a few insights about sales.
What is it like to run sales,
run a 100% sales team?
What are some of the,
I'm not coming from a sales background,
and I was an engineer myself,
yet almost every single person
that I meet that I ask,
what is your number one advice for me,
would say any advice
to any young entrepreneur.
Learn how to sell.
Learn how to be a good salesman.
Not necessarily the bad connotation
of the word, but be able to communicate
your message effectively
and convince others
of why your idea matters.
So, I'd love to hear your opinion on that.
Yeah. When I was in business schools,
sales was a four letter word, right?
You didn't want to get into sales.
You wanted to be in marketing.
That was where
the strategic smart people
would be at marketing.
The hustlers went into sales.
So, when I started my career,
I was a marketer,
a product manager as VP of marketing.
But once when I was a VP of marketing,
I would help out with the sales.
And I was at a startup where we went
through seven VPs of sales.
And each time we fired one, the CEO said,
"Hey, you know the product."
"Can you go in and try to close the deals?"
I go in and close the deals.
And after the seventh one was fired,
he said,
"Hey, every time we fire one
you go in and you close the deals."
"Why don't you just run sales?"
So, I learned how to run sales that way.
And I realized, it was really
the most important function at a company.
Because whether your product
is great or not,
you've got to get revenue for it
to keep the company going.
And those sales skills really helped me
when I was a CEO.
Because when you're CEO,
it's 100% sales.
You're selling investors.
You're selling the first employees.
You're selling the first customers.
And so, that's sales skill
is super valuable as an entrepreneur,
not just because sales
is such an important function,
but also because sales,
you're selling as a CEO all the time.
And so, I was fortunate to be able
to be an interim VP of sales.
Learn how important it was,
and then I use that skill
as my own company.
And then, this sales job I have now
is actually the first pure
sales job I've ever had.
I've been a VP of marketing.
I've been a GM.
I've been a CEO.
But I have those skills,
so, I was able to do it.
So then, how does somebody,
the growing trend is that
more and more young entrepreneurs
are coming from an engineering background
and they're very focused
on the technology.
How does one, like myself,
go and actually acquire
these hands on skills
and then ability to sell?
It doesn't sound like there's a good class
I could take at Stanford
called "How To Sell".
Yeah, because no one would take the class.
Because they all think
they don't want to do it.
There should be that class, by the way.
I think it would be
one of the best classes at Stanford,
but I don't think there is one.
Well, I think you might have to come
and teach it.
And I would definitely take it.
But now, seriously, I mean,
I'm going through my journey,
And how does a young entrepreneur
like myself, go and practice
these hands on skills
and gets better at it?
Yeah. So, the nice thing about sales
is that if you're empathetic
and a good listener,
you can learn how to do it.
But if you start a company,
you are going to learn
that your job is sales.
So, as an entrepreneur,
I think going into it,
know that if you decide
to start a company,
your job is going to be sales.
The product part is easier.
The harder part
is the investors and the employees,
and the first customers.
Especially those first customers
that are just buying on the mission.
Because version one of your product
isn't going to solve their problem.
It's going to give them
a path to solving the problem.
And so, you really have to convince them.
But, you'd be surprised
how much selling you do in your life.
Do you have a girlfriend?
Yeah. Yeah, I have a girlfriend.
All right.
You're selling her all the time, right?
So, I think part of it is just learning
that you're selling
all the time anyways.
And the formal sales part
is just a title, really.
Because everything you do
in your life is sales.
Whether it's relationships,
whether it's friendships,
whether it's investors.
You are, Michael,
probably a very good salesman.
Thank you.
And definitely, ,I do think that,
growing up in the entrepreneurship world,
I do notice that the word,
the four letter word does have
some negative connotation.
But I'm definitely thinking,
to what were you're saying
and this idea that at the end,
selling, it's not just going
and trying to get people to pay money
for something.
It's this whole idea
of how do you get people excited
about something
that you're bringing to the table.
Whether it's investors or employees,
or, your actual product, etc.
But Andy, then you're running
an organization of 100 salespeople.
And one of the things
that I'm always curious about is,
in sales, it only seems like it's very,
the commission driven incentive.
Like, I want to sell so that
I want to show that I sold the most.
And that means that I'm the best.
How do you create a healthy culture
that does have these motivations,
but is also mission driven
as a part of 100 person organization?
Yeah, so it's fortunate as a company
and Rene's done a great job of Bill.com
creating a great mission focus.
We're helping businesses
operate in the cloud, right?
And we've always been focused on that
in the last six months.
We're super focused on it.
So, we're actually helping small businesses
manage their cash flow
and stay in business
during these crazy times.
So, my sales team has that same mission.
We're really helping small businesses.
And then, for motivating salespeople,
yeah, it's the money,
but it's also your career.
What do you want to learn,
how do you want to grow.
Do you want to maximize your income,
or, do you want to be
a VP of sales someday?
And so, we spent a lot of time on my team
helping people grow.
And explain to them
it's not just the comp.
It's also, how do you get
to the next level.
What skills do you learn.
So, we do a lot of promoting from within
where we'll take people
that are just starting their sales career
and get them
to more senior selling positions,
or, get them to a manager position.
So, a lot of it is just making sure
we understand what people's goals are.
And then helping them achieve
their dreams.
Whether it's money or
responsibility or sales skills.
So, we do a lot of that.
And that's how we keep
the team motivated.
Sure, we're also trying
to have competitions.
And every day we have a leader board,
stack ranked on who's on top
and who's not.
If you're in sales,
you like that competition.
But also, it's helping people grow.
And it's not just the money.
It's also your career.
[--]
You don't feel that
the competitive side of it is eating away
from the mission side of it,
or creating a hostile environment?
You're saying it actually,
it just helps you be more diligent
and focus more
on what your motivations are.
And your responsibility as a leader
of such teams is to help people navigate
what are their motivations
and how do you help them get there
in the easiest way possible.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it could be cutthroat,
but it doesn't have to be cutthroat.
Right.
And then back to selling.
A lot of selling
that people don't understand,
it's not telling someone.
It's asking them questions.
So, when we use an application
called Chorus where we tape
people sales call,
so that we can understand
help them do better, train them.
And the good ones, it's the customer
or the prospect talking more than the rep.
So, a good rep is asking you
five or six key questions
and then leading you to,
Okay, if you've answer this way,
you need our product
if you answers or you don't.
So, a good salesperson in life
or is asking the right questions,
finding out how to help the person
they're talking to,
and then providing a solution
to that problem.
So, selling is really helping people
at a fundamental level.
If you have a problem
where you're spending three people
to open envelopes and write checks
and sign checks and it's cost you
a lot of money,
we can help you save money
and make your process more efficient.
We're helping you.
So,  good sales is finding a problem
and solving it.
It's not convincing someone
to do something
that they shouldn't do.
And, obviously,
one of the most greatest changes
that covid is bringing upon us
is this whole nature of sales.
And in my mind,
I'm imagining a sales relationship
is that you go, you meet in person.
You may be go out for dinner,
you demo the product in person.
And as a salesperson,
you're able to gauge the other person's,
how receptive they are
to what you're saying.
Now, you have to do a lot of this
over Zoom.
And, is there differences?
Are there more difficulties?
Where are we headed
in terms of the whole sales cycle?
Yeah. So, fortunately for us,
we were doing it over Zoom anyways.
So, it wasn't really a change.
You're all prepared.
I'm probably not the best person
to answer that question. Yeah.
Definitely. But it is something I think
that I've been thinking about.
how do you take a lot
of the core relationships that we have
in our daily lives,
and now that you've transitioned over Zoom
and you want to remain receptive?
And actually, I have some friends
who are thinking about
how do you actually leverage the fact
that these conversations are over Zoom
so that you can get even more insight
into your cell cycle,
like what's happening, of course.
Well, I will tell you
that people have more time to talk to you.
We're doing outbound and people
are spending less time in meetings,
and they're more available
to have these conversations.
And they're also, I think,
thinking more out of the box
than they were pre-covid,
on are there better ways to do things.
So, I think, for innovative technologies
it's a great time.
I love it. I love it.
Andy, this was so good.
I learned so much.
I want to thank you again for your time.
Before we leave,
I want to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah. So, I mean, you have to ask my wife
for the truth.
But I'll tell you what I think of myself.
So, I think determined.
I think it's all about persistence.
Life is 99% persistence.
So, I am persistent.
I'm also optimistic.
Because I think,
in business you have to be.
There's everything is always broken
and nothing is ever perfect.
And so, you have to be optimistic.
So, I think persistent and optimistic.
And then, the other thing is,
I'm just at this point,
I would say that I'm focused
on non-work as well
and just having a balanced life.
So, I think persistent, optimistic,
and just focused on balance too,
which is your energy to do the work.
My high school principal was always saying,
balance balance balance.
By the time we graduated,
we all knew that phrase
like in the back of our hands.
And, we're talking about balance
also involved with J-Ventures,
an early stage investing and then helping
other young companies grow up.
So, and we didn't even
get to talk about that.
But I love this idea.
And I learned so much.
So, thank you again, Andy.
This is really fantastic.
Michael, thank you.
Pleasure to meet you.
And hopefully our paths will cross again
in person someday.
Because that is still important.
100%.
Thank you, Andy. Toda raba.
Take care.
Bye bye.
Bye.